thank you
I think it might be a bad influence on
each other
hello June hello Jennifer
I've recorded some questions here and
I've left enough space for you to answer
[Music]
what do you think of your new school
or
rain
how was your day girls
I spoke to me and then it was just less
and less you know
if there's something you want to
communicate
foreign
[Music]
how would you describe your
personalities I think you might be a bad
influence on each other it might be an
idea to split you up for a while we will
move the girls into special education I
want to say anything we'll get them to
talk yeah guilty or not guilty you need
to take care of it you can at least say
something how do you plead
there shall be institutionalized
indefinitely
[Applause]
if you were telling your story
in order to write a good book you need
to feel it you have to be inspired
right here
[Music]
it's brought a new Awakening in me I
could reach out and touch the stuff I
can see the Galaxy can't go back to the
empty days before we found out I feel as
though I'm swimming in a pool Taste of
Bittersweet smell of salt
it's like God gave me a chance
the chance to prove Who I Really Am
[Music]